[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui privés 60,18 vous
emmène découvrir le graffiti je suis
avec deux heures le graffeur et avant de
vous présenter on se trouve au gratin de
menthe la ville vous connaissez bien cet
endroit alors est ce que vous pouvez me
présenter un petit peu les lieux c'est
un graff park qui a été inaugurée de
mémoire en 2008 parce que j'avais été
présent pendant trois cavités mais voilà
en tant que spectateur ils avaient
inauguré tout une fresque avec des
anciens et voilà c'était très cool donc
vous êtes un graffeur yves hinant et en
plus d'une passion pour vous le graffiti
c'est aussi un vecteur de lien social
exactement ça fait sept ans que je
dispense des ateliers des bétons
civilisation au street art donc
différentes structures gpda psychiatrie
pendant cinq ans et théophile roussel à
montesson jali le médico-social et le
graffiti donc aujourd'hui
l'apprentissage ça vous connaît et ça
tombe bien puisque vous allez me donner
un petit coup moi qui n'ai jamais touché
de bombes des graves qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qui est prévu ben là je sais
pas moi je vais partir serein des u
voilà c'est un truc un peu perso mes
amis comprendront et puis sa mère du
coup ouais exactement mais est en fait
quand je vais te montrer mon sac à main
il ya plein il ya pas des bombes j'étais
prix des cartes des skinny des fat des
médiums tu vas kiffer j'étais même pris
une petite paire de gants pas se cacher
alors y est en fait le graffiti c'est
pas compliqué ça regroupe
globalement trois styles le tag qui est
une signature tracé le flop qui est ce
qui est plutôt
entre l'intermédiaire entre le tag et le
graph donc c'est des lettres plutôt
arrondies et le graph qui sont des
lettres en volume donc là concrètement
tu vois tu peux te dire que le love
c'est un graphe ça c'est un flop vas-y
parfait ça c'est un flop et ça c'est un
panier
[Musique]
aux
places d'honneur est en train de poser
les bases du graff et ensuite moi je
crois que je vais intervenir pour
apporter man je crois au thé sûr
texter cas ce que j'explique mon petit
bixente
la partie nord va être en rouge et la
partie sud va être en bleu
c'est parti alors la distance idéale
c'est à peu près une cm là en gros tu va
remplir et en fait ce qu'on appelle un
remplissage électrique c'est à dire tu
remplis pas comme ça tu remplis comme ça
si jamais comme tu commences sur cet
héritage mes graphes et de ta vie piquer
des trucs comme ça c'est des z'acrau
d'accord tu es loin de toi un peu des
salles et
voilà monsieur savate et c'est pas beau
vert à bon bah oui après monde si c'est
pas grave c'est comme quand tu fais à
cuisiner tu t'en mets sur les doigts
c'est comme ça c'est quoi le le graff
dont il est le plus fier fin des graphes
que kita marques et est ce que tu en as
a way théophile roussel on est en équipe
on était avec des vrais en hôpital
psychiatrique là quand on a fait j'ai
organisé le premier festival en
psychiatrie quand même et c'était super
sympa
mais
bon pas des petits ronds dans les petits
rôles monsieur one niveau du placement
là ça peut être pas mal ici ça va si
après coup comme ça c'est bien ça fait
du faux
à la
halle à monsieur ensuite tu m'en faire
un petit palau
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
vous ma dernière ligne était pas été le
média les gars je dors maintenant
rattraper sans toujours les gars
toujours
[Musique]
on va faire un point de suite ça mais le
flou donc le point de fuite attends je
vais m ici tu vois quand fait tous les
traits en fait c'est ce qui est le plus
technique tous les traits tu vois je
vais les réunir vers le point bas la
fois remplir en noir
a
regardé regarder le show durant
toute la dernière étape je crois c'est
la finition exactement monsieur
[Musique]
voilà deux heures on a vu notre petit
graffiti fin j'ai petit au final ça
prend pas mal de places sur new york où
ce merci beaucoup je crois que j'ai
appris quelques bases il me reste encore
du travail avant d'arriver à votre
niveau c'est que d'expérience et du
travail c'est rien mais ça va tu es pas
mal j'ai bien hâte à capter des ailes
système des caps et où la distance mais
en tout cas pour découvrir le graffiti
vous pouvez vous rendre avec vos propres
2006 un espace en libre accès est ce
pour faire concentrer non voilée de ne
pas passer sur notre tag mais allez-y
est repassée moi les gars c'est un
terrain c'est fait pour ça il n'y a pas
de problème
est ce ma gueule y est
[Musique]